but is it true that queen latifah kind  of inspired you to start recording  well queen latifah at a co at a club  called nels  uh this is actually goes further back oh  wow  when i was a bouncer in new york anytime  i saw a musician i said i could rap i  have raps i have  flow i have borrows and she said do  something and i did this kind of  guttural sound that would later become  groot  and she said can you carry that through  a whole song later  in life about six years ago i was at a  oscar party and she said i would buy  a cd of you mumbling oh my gosh  and by the way um you mentioned it so  i'll talk about it um groot's my  favorite character  my mother and i we separately found this  out because i was like she had a little  groot and i was like is that your face  that's my favorite one  yeah you're our favorite just thank you  i'm a huge fan of guardians of the  galaxy  you win yep i'm still here just waiting  for you to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever